yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining how pixar's new
movie soul
proves the theory that all the studios
films take place in an interconnected
universe
i'll also show you how seoul explains
the toy story movies where the
incredibles get their powers and the
origins of the magical doorways in
monsters inc and brave
plus i'll explain how the new film fits
in with inside out and coco
of course there'll be some spoilers so
take care john negroni first introduced
the idea of a single pixar timeline
and its insoles the hall of everything
where we can find especially compelling
evidence to confirm negroni's theory
the hall is overflowing with specific
objects and locations which often recur
in pixar's films from the iconic pizza
planet truck to the blimp from up and
even the weirdly shaped rock called
willy's butte from the cars movies
and that's a huge pointer that the
movies exist in the same universe
but soul goes even further than this
because even though the film appears to
be set roughly in the present day which
i'm basing on the look and feel of new
york and the cell phone joe uses
the hall of everything even has objects
from the future
such as the axiom from wally one of a
fleet of giant starliners that wasn't
used until 2105
when by and large arranged for the
evacuation of the earth
this implies that the hall of everything
may even contain blueprints or at least
the inspiration for events that are
still to come in the future of the pixar
universe
soul also demonstrates one of the most
important concepts at the heart of
negroni's pixar theory that humans are
batteries
the idea is that human beings are a
source of energy to sentient objects
such as the toys and toy story which is
why they crave the love of their owners
otherwise it's suggested that if the
toys end up stored away they lose their
life
and in monsters inc we know that
technology exists that can harvest
energy from human emotions such as fear
or joy
and there are several moments in soul
that strongly support this idea of
humans as an
energy source when joe is on the
elevator that leads to the great beyond
he notices that as the souls of the
recently deceased float up into the big
bright light
they fizzle and crackle like an
electrical charge
[Music]
as if to reinforce this idea that a soul
is a form of energy there's also an
electrical crackle sound effect whenever
we see
terry counting souls on her abacus
joe also discovers in the great before
that before new souls can take their
place on earth they not only have to
acquire a set of personalities but they
also need what the movie calls a spark
to complete that personality
without this spark theoretically a soul
isn't allowed to go to earth and live a
human life
22 does end up on earth by accident but
the general rule is that a spark is
needed to complete the earth pass which
a soul needs to live a life
the word spark can of course mean a
number of things such as a burst of
electricity or an intense
feeling or emotion which again points to
this idea of human beings as a form of
energy or batteries even
another crucial element of negroni's
pixar theory is the idea that boo from
monsters inc
travels back in time to become the witch
in brave i'll get to how seoul supports
this idea shortly but
first let's quickly recap what the
theory says about time travel
brave is set in 10th century scotland
whereas given the monster's advanced
technology monsters inc
takes place in the future the clearest
evidence which suggests time travel is
the wood carving of sully that the witch
has in her cottage
she's also obsessed with bears which
could be her way of expressing the
strong friendship she made with sully in
monsters inc
on top of that the witch has carvings of
the pizza planet truck which should be
impossible given that motorised vehicles
most definitely didn't exist in medieval
scotland
and she's carved parodies of famous art
by
artists from the future like
michelangelo the door to the witch's
cottage is also magical and can
transport her into an alternate interior
version of her hut
and it can also make her disappear this
is because boo
learned how the technology of the portal
doors at the monsters inc factory worked
which is how she traveled through time
and space
crucially in seoul we can see this same
technology in the youth seminar
after souls are paired up with their
mentor jerry conjures up a door and
sends them through it
instantly transporting them to another
location
and when jerry gives joe his second
chance to return to earth he passes from
the great beyond through a door
and emerges on earth through another
door given the great before existed at
the beginning of time
it suggests that the technology for
magical portals in the pixar universe
was originally born there
seoul also makes a sneaky possible
reference to boo's time travel
shenanigans in what initially appears to
be a throwaway line by one of the jerrys
when terry turns up to complain that the
count is out by one soul
jerry replies i seriously doubt that the
count hasn't been off in centuries
this is a vital piece of information for
pixar theorists because it tells us that
an anomaly
similar to joe escaping the elevator
that was taking him to the great beyond
has happened previously
several hundred years ago in fact to
understand what may have happened all
those centuries ago
let's look at what happened when joe's
soul accidentally fell into the body of
mr mittens
why am i in a cat i don't know
it seems that mr mitten's soul was sent
off to the great beyond
so what if boo did a similar thing when
she time traveled to medieval scotland
could she have landed in the body of a
scottish woman and displaced her soul
sending it up to the great beyond that
would mean there'd be an
extra soul in the afterlife without a
corresponding dead body on earth
which could be the reason for the count
being off as jerry said
interestingly when joe returns to his
body and soul mr mittens appears to
regain his original soul too
as we see him reunite with his owner so
if my theory about boo and the witch's
soul is correct it makes me wonder
whether terry did anything about the
anomaly that occurred in the soul count
hundreds of years ago by the way it's
worth pointing out that there's also a
brave easter egg and soul during the
video at the youth seminar when we see a
soul find its spark after it
successfully shoots an arrow into the
center of one of three targets
referencing merida's demonstration of
archery skills when she
fired arrows into three targets and
there are of course
many more pixar easter eggs in seoul
including the chinese takeout box a113
and the luxo
ball all of which i reveal in my full
easter eggs video
now there are two pixar movies inside
out and coco which on the surface
seem to contradict soul and maybe pose a
problem for how smoothly it fits into
the interconnected universe of the pixar
theory
the first issue is to do with
personality in the great before we
discover that every soul acquires a set
of personalities before they go to earth
this is where personalities come from of
course do you think people are just born
with them however in inside out
personalities are formed whenever a new
core memory is made
each core memory powers a different
aspect of riley's personality
the islands of personality are what make
riley
riley while these ideas about
personality may appear to be at odds
with one another
they can be easily reconciled if we
think of a newborn soul
as having a baseline personality at
birth some of which adapts and changes
as that person grows up and has
different experiences
in fact in inside out we see that riley
loses her personalities when she
experiences a traumatic event
however these are later restored and new
ones are also added as she grows up
so an individual's personality is
clearly not something static or
unchanging
likewise soul also shows us how 22's
personality changes as she experiences
life on earth
something else we need to reconcile is
how coco's land of the dead fits with
seoul's depiction of the great beyond
in seoul the afterlife is a relatively
simple place with an escalator that
leads souls to a giant white light in
the sky
this representation may be alluding to
the idea that many people who report
near-death experiences describe a tunnel
with a bright light at the end that
draws them towards it
coco's spirit world on the other hand is
complex and bursting with colours with
the marigold bridge forming a connection
between the land of the living and the
elaborate and complex land of the dead
fear not though because we can resolve
these differences by turning to pixar's
official the art of soul book which
describes the great beyond as a place
beyond all that can be known
represented by a brilliant white light
in a vast space
what lies beyond the light is all up to
interpretation
as the book suggests we can interpret
what's beyond the bright light in our
own way
and so we can see the land of the dead
in cocoa as a culturally specific vision
of what the afterlife is
unique to people of mexican heritage
this would also explain how cocoa can
have its own specific rules for its
spirit world such as allowing the dead
to cross over to the land of the living
one day each year
what's common to both soul and coco
though is that the dead souls all retain
the appearance and age they had at the
time of their death
whereas in the great before all the
souls look more or less similar
likely because they haven't taken a
human form yet
the sparks that a soul acquires may even
explain where the supers in the
incredibles got their powers
could it be that the souls that ended up
as superheroes were supercharged with
extra powers by the spark they received
in the great before there is after all
the statue of what looks like a caped
hero on a plinth in the hall of
everything
maybe that statue is responsible for
sparking the unfortunate idea of
caped superheroes knuckles and this is
just a fun idea but could the soul
that's being interviewed here for the
youth seminar training video be the soul
of buddy pine aka syndrome
i'm a manipulative megalomaniac who's
intensely opportunistic oh this one
might be a handful
but that's earth's problem perhaps
syndrome got his spark from that statue
because after all it was his cape that
proved to be his ultimate
undoing and yes syndrome wasn't born
with powers but that statue might have
inspired him to seek glory in whatever
way he could
or could that soul be evel endeavour the
master manipulator and evil tech genius
from the second incredibles movie
the soul's possibly female sounding
voice might
also suggest this although we know from
22 that a soul can change their voice to
sound like any type of person
i could sound like this if i wanted to
or sound like this instead
i could even sound like you if you like
either of these ideas leave a thumbs up
or comment below with which other pixar
character you think this troublemaking
soul could be
now i want to thank our sponsor nordvpn
for helping make this video happen
if you want to keep yourself safe and
secure whenever you're online from spies
and snoopers like terry from the great
beyond you'll need to get yourself a
trustworthy virtual private network
a vpn protects your privacy by
encrypting your internet connection and
preventing your internet service
provider the government or hackers from
knowing what websites you're visiting or
reading your private messages
a vpn is also a powerful tool that helps
you bypass
geolocation blocks so you can access
content not available to view or
censored in your country unlike many
free vpns
nord works with disney plus netflix and
amazon prime and you can connect up to
six devices at any one time so you can
secure
all your laptops computers phones
tablets and even home router
something we especially like about nord
is the super fast
download speeds on its 5000 plus servers
and how it uses new generation vpn
technologies like wire guard
on top of that nord has a no log policy
meaning it doesn't record or retain
details of your online activity when
you're connected to its service
with our exclusive seasonal offer you
can get a full
four bonus months completely free and
68 off whenever you sign up for a
two-year plan
just visit nordvpn.comflix or tap the
link in the video description to access
the offer
this is one of the biggest deals of the
year so go visit nordvpn.comflix for
this limited time
offer now do you have any more ideas on
how soul fits into the pixar theory
and if you enjoyed any of my soul
theories a thumbs up is hugely
appreciated
you can also tap left to discover where
all the other pixar easter eggs are in
the movie
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yupikai movie lovers